This is an African pouched rat. They're particularly good at detecting TNT and
landmines. They're trained using something called tea eggs, which have TNT in
them. TNT is an explosive found in many land mines. If the African pouched rats
were able to find the tea eggs. They were given a food reward. But if they
scratched near tea eggs that did not contain TNT, then they did not receive a
food reward. Scratching near the tea eggs was considered the indicator response.
The researchers found that the training was very successful in teaching the rats
to detect real landmines in the field. This was measured by the number of meters
of land cleared by explosives. And by the number of landmines that they found.
Based on this study, what can we say is true?